esta vez quiero mostrar que 0.5 es igual
a un medio y seguramente has visto a
alguien usar estos dos como si fueran
iguales intercambiar 0.5 por un medio no
sé tal vez escuchaste decir a alguien
yo vi una rata de 1.5 kilogramos y
alguien más replicó una rata de kilo y
medio
eso es enorme y bueno si pensamos un
poco en lo que dijeron y dejamos de lado
la rata enorme puedes darte cuenta que
una de estas personas dijo 1.5 y la otra
dijo kilo y medio es decir hicieron este
intercambio porque saben que son iguales
es por eso que se usa esta igualdad 0.5
y un medio son equivalentes es decir son
iguales pero antes de dar esto por
sentado vamos a ver si podemos probarlo
intentemos probarlo y lo primero que voy
a hacer es mostrarte que aquí tengo una
recta
la cual va de 0 a 1 y está dividida en 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 secciones iguales
entonces eso significa que la distancia
que hay de aquí hasta acá de aquí hasta
acá es de un décimo esta es una de 10
secciones iguales y por lo tanto es un
décimo de toda esta distancia de 0 a 1
así que si regresamos y vemos ahora este
decimal que tengo aquí bueno pues puedes
ver a este de la siguiente manera 0.5 es
lo mismo que cinco decimos otra forma de
escribir este decimal es decir que
tenemos cinco décimos
o podemos decir que esto es lo mismo que
5 sobre 10 5 decimos entonces si la
distancia de aquí a camps es de un
décimo y seguimos caminando la distancia
de aquí a camps va a ser de otro décimo
y llegamos a dos décimos dos de estos
diez lugares iguales y entonces para
llegar a cinco décimos tenemos que
caminar uno
45 de estas secciones iguales justo aquí
en este punto estoy llegando al valor de
5 decimos lo podemos escribir como una
fracción o lo podemos escribir en su
forma decimal como 0.5 muy bien una vez
que ya encontramos a cinco décimos oa
0.5 en la recta numérica vamos a ver si
en verdad este decimal es lo mismo que
un medio y para eso vamos a observar la
distancia que hay de 0 hasta 1 y vamos a
hacer con esta distancia un bloque vamos
a apuntar estos dos porque vamos a hacer
un bloque con esta distancia y al
enmarcar esta distancia vamos a fijarnos
en dónde está un medio bien si dividimos
esta distancia a la mitad más o menos
aquí es la mitad y dibujo toda esta
parte observa que me estoy tomando un
medio d
lo que y entonces este punto de aquí en
donde estamos cortando a este bloque a
la mitad observamos que toman el mismo
valor de 5 decimos nos dan toda esta
distancia que hemos recorrido y podemos
ver aquí que en efecto la mitad de la
distancia entre 0 y 1 es la mitad del
camino que tenemos aquí donde llegábamos
a 0.5 entonces aquí tenemos a un medio y
acabamos de ver que llegamos al mismo
punto en la recta numérica entonces esta
es una forma de probar que son
equivalentes otra forma que se me ocurre
para probar que son equivalentes es la
siguiente y para esto lo que puede hacer
es dibujar una fracción y lo primero que
voy a hacer es tomarme por aquí un
rectángulo muy bien y ahora qué te
parece si empezamos con un
y medio y para eso lo que voy a hacer es
dividir a este rectángulo en dos
secciones iguales los voy a dividir a la
mitad y vamos a sombrear una de estas
partes así que voy a sombrear todo esto
una de mis dos secciones iguales y eso
me va a dar lo mismo que uno
y ahora vamos a probar que esto es igual
a 0.5 y bueno recuerda que este 5 está
en la posición de los décimos de sí
decimos y es por eso que esto lo podemos
ver como 5 decimos así que ahora en
lugar de dividir a este rectángulo a la
mitad vamos a dividirlo en 10 partes
iguales
bien pues vamos a hacerlo y para eso voy
a dividir a este rectángulo en 10
secciones iguales y primero lo que voy a
hacer es dividirlo en cinco secciones
verticales 1 2 3 4 y 5 y ya están y
ahora lo que voy a hacer es dividir todo
este rectángulo de nuevo a la mitad y ya
tengo 10 secciones iguales y ahora lo
que vamos a hacer es sombrear cinco de
ellas así que veamos una de ellas
cuatro y cinco de ellas
aquí tenemos sombreadas cinco de estas
diez secciones lo cual puedes ver que es
lo mismo que un medio un medio es igual
a 0.5 o cinco décimos porque cubren la
misma área la misma cantidad y por eso
son iguales y ya está aquí puedes ver
que mostramos que un medio es igual a
0.5 de dos maneras distintas primero
usamos una recta numérica y observamos
que llegamos al mismo punto lo que
significa que son iguales y después
probamos que cubren la misma área y esa
es otra forma de decir que son iguales
entonces en definitiva un médium es
igual a 0.5
cinco décimos